in 1976 Carlo Chipola a professor of
economic history derived as social law
by which we can group people into four
categories the first he called the
helpless the second are the intelligent
the third are the bandits and the last
are the stupid
[Music]
the stupid person is the most dangerous
type of person and in groups far more
powerful than the Mafia the military or
communism Chipola warned to arrive at
this conclusion we need to understand
his five basic laws of human stupidity
[Music]
foreign
ly everyone underestimates the number of
stupid individuals in circulation
2. the probability that a person is
stupid is independent of any other
characteristic of that person education
wealth or status have nothing to do with
it
3. a stupid person is someone who causes
losses to other people while himself
deriving no gain
4. non-stupid people always
underestimate the damaging power of
stupid people and keep forgetting that
to deal with stupid people always turns
out to be a costly mistake
5. a stupid person is the most dangerous
type of person even more dangerous than
a bandit
Chipola then considers four factors of
human behavior a person can cause
benefits to others benefits to
themselves losses to others and losses
to themselves if Tom takes an action and
suffers a loss he's helpless if Tom
benefits himself while also benefiting
Jerry he's intelligent if Tom helps
himself but causes Jerry a loss he's a
bandit and if Tom does something that's
of no benefit to him but causes Jerry a
loss he's stupid
ineffectual people are in this Center
let's now look at the effects of these
groups on society
foreign
helpless people contribute to society
but have taken advantage of by others
especially Bandits and so their
contribution is limited note that
extreme altruists or pacifists may
willingly accept a place in this
category for moral reasons
intelligent people contribute to society
and leverage their contributions into
reciprocal benefits their actions lead
to a net gain to society which is why
helpless people should always support
intelligent ones
Bandits pursue their own self-interest
and enrich themselves even when doing so
poses a harm to society helpless and
intelligent people should try to stop
them
stupid people always contribute to a net
loss to society but not only that as
they do so for no obvious reason their
actions also for a straight anger and
confuse everyone else
against major cultural Trends among his
fellow intellectuals Chipola was
convinced that men are not equal that
some are stupid and others are not and
that the difference is determined by
nature and nothing else one is stupid in
the same way one is red-haired he wrote
Chipola warned that the damaging
potential of the stupid person therefore
depends on the amount of stupidity
inherited as well as their position of
power in a society
among bureaucrats generals and
politicians one has little difficulty in
finding clear examples of basically
stupid individuals whose damaging
capacity was alarmingly enhanced by the
position of power they occupied
what are your thoughts on stupidity are
people born or made stupid or is it as
usual more complex and is there an
interrelationship between the two share
your thoughts and read more about
chipola's work and amusing essay which
originally was only intended for friends
in the descriptions below
foreign
if you found this helpful check out our
other videos and subscribe if you want
to support our work join us on
patreon.com sprouts for more information
and additional content visit
sproutschools.com